You know,
look over the last decade or so,
I think the biggest shift we've seen as
sort of the final breakdown of the
traditional channel based structure of
the way we tend to think about
communications as paid media,
earned media owned media,
um,
this sort of sort of traditional siloed
approach to communications that we still
hear a lot from marketing textbooks and
business school and that kind of thing.
Um,
I think what has happened is that the
process of the law,
the 20 years proceeding the last decade
was about fragmentation,
right?
New Types of channels,
um,
satellite TV and mobile networks and
just as incredible proliferation of
types of content and channels within the
silos that left people feeling like they
had infinite choice but left
communicators feeling like it was
impossible to reach an audience.
What social media has done,
particularly facebook and twitter have
created a glue to knit all these
fragments back together into something
that feels like one big graph,
one big network of content moving
between channels and unpredictable ways
of engaging with people in ways that we
can't necessarily predict of creating
more.
Two directional conversational dialogues
and communication between individuals
and and the people that we're trying to
reach and inspire,
which is new behavior for us.
It requires marketers and communicators
and publishers to develop new skills
like listening,
right?
That we didn't used to have to do,
We just pick the channel and we pick the
right message and we said something to
an audience that was mostly pretty
passive.
And I think this is the big shift in
thinking.
And the real challenge for a lot of
organizations is the world.
We are now part of a graph with the
people that we're trying to inspire
rather than them being a stable audience
that we're trying to reach.
And us being in a stable position as
inspire or publisher,
we now have to participate in the
system,
right?
People create content,
we create content,
they share content,
we share content.
And that means that we have to think
differently about how we communicate,
how we tell stories,
how much content we have to create.
We can't reliably predict where that
content is going to get consumed.
So it's really easy to get into a
situation where if we're not really
clear about our values and our identity
and who we are and what we're trying to
achieve,
where sort of our values and mission sit
as an organization,
it can become really easy to sound
schizophrenia to the communities that
we're trying to engage.
And I think a lot of organizations are
still really struggling with this
transition.
It's still feels really unsettling to
folks because it means wholescale
changing of the way we think about
content and communication and publishing
even means different,
you know,
different org charts.
Rethinking how we shape the
organizations and design and staff and
how teams work together and how people
collaborate are all different than they
used to be.
And that's still a change process that I
think a lot of a lot of us in a lot of
organizations are still working their
way through.
So when we think about politics and we
think about what's changed in
communications,
one of the most important changes to the
communication landscape is the shift
from the necessity of being able to
listen effectively at scale.
Right?
The necessity of seeing the people that
were engaging as relationships we're
trying to create and the necessity of
empathy and listening as part of
starting relationships is fundamental to
communication now rather than either
orthogonal or accidental or you know,
a nice to have,
you know,
this is the fundamental nature of many
of the communication mechanisms.
We use our bi directional now and that
means our habits have to change.
Yeah,
I mean I think one of the,
one of the great advantages of digital
technologies is the capacity to listen
and scale.
That's something that wasn't possible
before.
Digital tools,
right?
The,
the ability to,
to take,
to use data and to use smart sort of
tools and listening to listening tools,
you know,
things like radian six and crimson
hexagon and there are a lot of these
platforms out there for the sort of UCM,
mostly in sort of enterprise marketing
spaces,
but work really well in politics and
social good and these other places to
get a sense for what people believe in,
think in social conversations.
Because so much of this conversation is
happening in public.
And so the question about listening is
mostly a cultural one,
right?
The tools,
it's tools aren't perfect and they're
not all,
you know,
some of them are pretty expensive.
So not necessarily the easiest things to
implement and building skills and hiring
people and thinking about this as,
as a skill set that needs to be part of
your team as part of this process.
But before any of that is a belief that
listening is important but a belief and,
and creating a culture where questioning
your own certainty and validating your
own certainty and putting the community
first in terms of how,
how you want to be able to reach and
inspire the people that you're trying to
engage,
whether that's selling a product or
trying to win an election,
right?
These things are,
this is just a function of how the
landscape works.
This is not particularly partisan.
It's not particularly about politics,
um,
but it requires a cultural belief in the
value of listening,
which is not something that,
that all leaders come by naturally.
Um,
and I think part of,
part of this is a discussion about the
value of empathy,
right?
And of the value of really the necessity
of understanding the values and beliefs
and emotions behind what people value
and believe as part of building real
relationships with people.
Um,
and this is where again,
digital tools make starting
relationships with more people easier,
but maintaining relationships is still
work,
right?
So this is one of the great challenges
of large scale community organizing,
which is the things that we were able to
do,
particularly back in 2008 with the first
Obama campaign when we were sort of
treading a lot of new ground just
because timing has a lot to do with the
success of a rain dance,
the,
that there's,
it created the ability for us to have
millions of volunteers,
which we could never have recruited
without these new platforms.
We just couldn't have had that many
meetings are we just wrote,
have run out of hours in the day and
time in the campaign.
And it allowed us to accelerate the
recruiting process and the engagement
process by creating more doors and more
ways into the campaign for more people.
But mainly making sure all of those
millions of people felt valuable.
And heard and respected and part of the
process and enabled to do good work that
had value that was on mission is an
enormous commitment of work and there
are thousands of field organizers in the
Obama community who did the work of
supporting those relationships.
And I think this is one of the big
shifts in thinking about from audience
to community,
right?
Where speaking at someone and saying the
right thing to you at the right time in
the right channel is a very linear
process,
right?
This is traditional microtargeting and
marketing,
right?
I need to figure out what you're
listening to or what you're watching so
I can show you the right message and
you're just going to consume it and it's
going to change your mind.
It's like this is a little bit the sort
of the Magic Madman idea,
right?
Like the perfect dad,
the perfect sort of great idea and there
is value to that.
Creativity and content is still super
central to how we communicate and how we
tell stories.
But the process is not that linear
anymore.
And so thinking about how we engage
people as a relationship we are building
over time rather than just a transaction
at a moment in time is this is I think
the starting point to start bringing
these other ideas into the conversation
about empathy and what you think and
believe and feel and listening to you.
And people will tell you what they think
if you ask them.
This is the other,
you know,
people ask a lot of,
how do you know what people think?
And the answer is in politics we knock
on a lot of doors and we have a lot of
conversations,
hundreds of millions of them,
literally conversations where we are
asking questions and talking to voters
and asking what they think and who they
support.
And we keep all that data.
It is a massive listening exercise.
It's a massive exercise in is,
is our view and vision for the future
compelling and is it getting through,
are we making sense?
Are we reaching people and connecting
with people in a way that is relevant to
them?
Or are we missing something?
Um,
and people will tell you if you ask
them,
it's not actually that complicated.
It's just,
it's hard to do at scale.
And this is something that has to be
staffed for,
and the law,
the,
the piece of this that I think if the
first part is about culture or the last
part is about adjusting to,
there is a misconception that you can
just start publishing and just create a
page.
No one,
God,
you don't,
no one charges you or anything.
You just start doing stuff.
Creating content isn't free.
Responding to comments isn't free.
Being careful about the ladder of
engagement you're creating with people
and inspiring them and engaging with
them and answering their questions isn't
free.
Right?
That requires teams and talent and
energy and commitment to creativity that
you got to pay for.
And that's a place the staffing changes.
And the way this changes the way we
think about like communications
departments is pretty profound.